there's a video that's gone viral of a
little girl getting beaten up on a bus
we've blurred the face of the victims
here
it's a nine-year-old girl being beaten
up by what appears to be a high school
student on a bus
you can see this poor little girl you
make out the size of your body
relatively obviously quite small in the
just absolute animal is this huge
kit is obviously much much older it's
just it's heinous that's all I can watch
of it and we still blurred
learn a lot of it
uh horrible scene in a way it's good
that the kids have cell phones now you
wish that any of the people with cell
phones who videotape these crimes would
put the phone down and go help but they
don't do that at least they're
videotaping it so that we can see it
though so what are we going to do about
it
what are we going to do about it the
answer
in a lot of blue States and a lot of
blue cities
which is where a lot of this stuff is
taking place the answer sadly is nothing
and the reason we're going to do nothing
about it is because
the decision Maker's kids will never
have to go to that school
the people who are responsible
for
a harsher discipline for protecting
students for increasing educational
outcomes they have zero incentive to do
that
that kid who that giant animal who was
Pub pummeling that poor little girl
he got a citation for it
kids should be in juvie I don't know how
old he is I hope he's not 18. he's 18 he
should be imprisoned but if he's
under 18 you should be in juvie for that
that's that is psycho behavior that is
not just kids get into a scrap on the
playground I don't think we need to call
the cops every time a couple of boys get
into a fight on the playground at recess
okay but when a giant hulking animal
teenager starts pummeling some poor
little nine-year-old girl on the school
bus relentlessly pummeling her that kid
needs to go to juvie okay
I don't I don't think that's so extreme
but it won't happen that none of that
stuff will happen
because
the the incentives to to help now are
only if your kids go to that school the
lawmakers kids won't go to that school
and for the purposes of Justice which
which most lawmakers don't seem to care
about these days and our whole culture
mocks the idea of justice and
retribution and a moral order and
tradition so that's at the window and
then what are the disincentives to do
anything the moment that you go in and
try to fix these schools the teacher
unions are going to come after you like
crazy and because these these incidents
are often happening in Democrat areas
the Democrats are totally in the pocket
of the teacher Union
so that's not going to do anything
in the moment you get involved
especially if it's a school with a lot
of black students at it you're going to
be called a racist you're going to be
any anything you try to do to reform
music schools you're going to be called
a racist people who try to offer
educational Alternatives like charter
schools are called racist somehow for
improving the educational outcomes of
black students somehow you're still
called so and racist is the worst thing
you can be called in society there's an
absolutely no incentive there
and there's lots of other problems and
hey we got to talk about that stupid
balloon in the sky so no one is going to
pay attention to it it's it's sad I wish
that we could do something but what and
also what are we going to do
when it's it's happening in Liberal
areas
and when even the federal government is
entirely controlled by the libs
just not going to happen other than the
House of Representatives we can call
some hearings it's not it's not going to
matter and it's not going to matter not
just because of certain bad people in
office it's not going to matter because
of the very structural problems it's
especially when it comes to education
you know what I want to talk about
Well everybody's talking about the
balloon I want to talk about
the upending of our culture I want to
talk about the deliberate
plan by our ruling Elites to blot out an
important swath of American culture and
it's not just me talking about it
Senator Josh hawley's talking about it
as well
now they said inflation was transitory
they said Russia's economy would crumble
under the sanctions of course China did
the big backdoor bailout buying their
oil their AG other countries followed
suit you know we could go on and on with
their failed predictions
have they gotten anything right here
no they haven't Laura but I do I will
tell you this they are getting what they
wanted in an ultimate sense which is
they want to remake our economy Joe
Biden wants to remake our economy such
that we don't have any more blue-collar
work in this country we don't have jobs
for working people all of those folks
have to depend on the government and all
we have instead is this this climate
green economy where you have to have a
fancy degree where you have to get a
white collar job in a big city and if
you want to live in the middle of the
country there are no jobs for you that's
what they want they don't like blue
collar workers they don't like blue
collar culture and so they're trying to
wipe it out by changing our economy and
Laura they are succeeding we have got to
stop them
Joe Biden wants to remake our economy
such that we don't have any more
blue-collar work in this country we
don't have jobs for working people
all of those folks have to depend on the
government that's his claim and it's
going to be written off by the Liberals
and by the squishes and the liberal
adjacent Republicans as just a bunch of
populist demagoguery here we go here's
Josh Hawley trying to rile up the people
what he's saying is obviously true the
way that we know it's true is that the
elites talk about it openly
they say oh we've got these bitter
clingers out there we've got these
deplorable
irredeemable people they just need to go
away
that's what the libs say and then what
what do the squishes on the right say
they write long articles about how small
town America needs to die
about how it's good that blue-collar
jobs or not even blue collars I guess
just what are it's called unskilled jobs
are shipped overseas
it's it's funny that that these jobs are
called unskilled because as you see the
Advent of artificial intelligence and
chat gbt you're noticing that the jobs
that are most at risk of being replaced
right now actually are white collar jobs
it's it's actually accountants some
kinds of business people journalists
actually the only people who have at
this moment lost their jobs as a result
of chat GPT our BuzzFeed journalists
whose work is now going to be done by
this computer so there's a kind of irony
to that
but the way that this is working in
practice does not change the plans and
dreams of the ruling class which they
say is get rid of the small town stuff
this blue collar stuff nobody learn to
code
so they learn to code You Blue Collar
idiots why then you can be like me you
can be living in a tiny little pod
apartment in a major Metropolitan City
with no family writing listicles for
BuzzFeed all day long about how terrible
small town America is that learn to code
idiots
now of course what what is actually
happening
because of the Advent of artificial
technology the new slogan is learn to
weld as as all the journo jobs getting
taken away say actually maybe you should
learn Plumbing learn to plumb huh learn
to weld don't learning to code is not
going to help you very well chatgpt is
going to code a lot better than you can
but but the point
we can we can get a kick out of the the
difference between the the liberal
Elites plans and what's actually
happening in practice
but the plans are important because we
need to know what's our response to it
what's our vision here they have a
political Vision their political vision
is get rid of all the the rube idiot
deplorable irredeemable Americans we
need to get rid of our political
Traditions our local communities our
subsidiarity we need to get rid of a lot
of our national sovereignty ship it all
off to those Geniuses and Davos the
world economic forum and the other
International institutions just give
them all the power let them run our
lives and that way we can all just sit
in pods and eat bugs and all be
androgynous and there are no men and
there are no women there's nothing
ornate or distinctive or beautiful or
traditional about life that's their plan
in a nutshell
so what's our vision
unfortunately in recent decades on the
right
our vision has been pretty much the same
in recent decades on the right because
of a a
very shallow
misunderstanding of what Liberty means
we've pretty much gone along with that
we've said oh yeah
on the gender stuff we say do whatever
you want just don't make me pay for it
that's fine though you can chop off your
body parts or have whatever kind of
weird sex stuff you want to do that's
totally fine no big deal
and on small town America yeah why would
you want to stay in small town America
let's go to Wall Street baby greed is
good let's do it we're all going to be
Gordon Gekko we're going to be Leo
DiCaprio and that Wolf of Wall Street
movie yeah man let's we're gonna be Iron
let's go do it
and then
in just in terms of the economy itself
we've been told that creative
destruction is the greatest thing
possible we just need prophets Above All
Else boost up that GDP ship all our jobs
overseas that's fine because GDP might
go up and we'll get cheap junk from
China and then because the junk that
China makes is going to be cheaper than
what we could make here in the United
States then everybody's going to make a
little bit more money as consumers we're
going to be a consumer society that that
just has a little bit more profit margin
for corporations won't that be great
that's what we're conserving there was
always this schizophrenia to Republican
political speeches over the last 20 30
years which is on the one hand they said
we need to defend traditional American
values small town America change begins
at the dinner table also
we need creative destruction do whatever
you want yeah you don't we should loosen
up the marriage laws yeah that's totally
fine we can have divorce we can have
people shouldn't have large families
yeah we can just move to the cities and
ship our jobs overseas and that's a
great thing
what are we conserving
are we only conserving profits there are
many people on the right
who if you got them if you had a couple
drinks with them like the undercover
journalist with Pfizer
they would admit that to you they'd say
yeah that's what we're conserving
they would use it would say a little
more euphemistically they'd say we're
conserving Liberty
but by Liberty they don't mean an
exalted Liberty they don't mean the
Edmund Burke kind of Liberty they don't
mean the founding fathers George
Washington kind of Liberty
that is circumscribed by a a pretty well
defined view of Morality In the way
Society is supposed to work and our
roles in society and gender roles and
social roles and all the rest no they
just mean
go go do whatever you want whenever you
want to do it
what are we concerned we'd just be
conserving leftism at that point
it's music Monday we got some great
music today the rest of the show
continues now if you're not a member
become a member dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout get two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign